رسمه بيتزا سلاح بالمجان ينتظره
الاوكرانيون لكسب الحرب ضد روسيا هذا
السلاح ليس من صناعه الغرب بل من صناعه
الصوفيه بل من طبيعه اوكرانيا والمنطقه
راثبيتزا فتره انتقاليه للطقس ينتظرها
الاوكرانيون بفارغ الصبر حيث ستعقد
التحركات العسكريه في ساحات القتال
المخاوف تتزايد من الجو جانب الروسي من
الطين الخريف الذي سيكون سببا في عرقله
مسار العمليات العسكريه في شرقي وجنوبي
اوكرانيا مع ابتلاء الطرقات بالوحل انا
جمعان ذوبان الثلوج فوفقا مراقبين القوات
الروسيه ستتكبت خسائر كبيره تزامنا مع
موسم ما يعرف براسبه وهي الفتره الرطبه
الموحله التي يتسببها ذوبان الثلوج في
الربيع والامطار الغزيره في فصل الخريف
حيث ستصبح مشاهدينا عمليه نقل الجنود
الروس والعتاد الحربي الروسي من مدرعات
ودبابات ونقلات جنود فوق الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
المتجمده صعبه جدا مما يجعلها عرضا للصيد
بانظمه الدفاع المضاده للدروع وابرزها
صواريخ جافيلد وهنا الجيش الاوكراني سيكون
قادرا على المضيق قدما في دومباز والسعاده
خيرسون ومواصله الدفع بزخم في الجنوب
والشمال الشرقي قبل بدء الفتره الموحله
التي ستوقف تقدم القوات الروسيه وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه فتره راسبوتيتا
ستجلب معها ظروفا صعبه للجيش الروسي وفرصا
للجيش الاكرانيا الذي سيتمكن من استهداف
خزانات الوقود وقوافل الامدادات الروسيه
ووضع الجنود الروس في مواجهه الدراجات
الحراره المنخفضه التي قد تميتهم تجمدا
كما ستساهم في مضاعفات تحركات الجيش الاوك
الذي لا يستعمل كثيرا الاسلحه الثقيله بل
اسلحه تكنولوجيه جديده على عكس روسيا التي
ستضطر الى التوقف بسبب استخدامها الدبابات
والمدرعات والمدفعيه الثقيله فما اقتراب
هذا الموسم ستصبح الحرب البريه اكثر صعوبه
وستصبح معها مهام اعاده امداد الخطوط
الاماميه اكثر صعوبه كما ستواجه المدفعيه
صعوبه في التحرك لاستخدام اطلاق النار
والهرب مما سيجعل استخدام المدفعيه اكثر
خطوره لكلال الشريف
[موسيقى]